we've grown so accustomed to being ruled
by elderly politicians who are decaying
in front of us that it's easy to forget
how abnormal this actually is but the
truth is that there are countries in the
world where the vast majority of elected
officials are middle-aged and even
capable of if you can believe it
completing sentences one of these
countries is Sweden Sweden's Parliament
is among the youngest in the world the
Prime Minister speaker first Deputy
speaker second Deputy speaker are all
under the age of 60. this is a
long-running trend in that country which
elected its youngest parliament in 2014
going back for the last decade or so
Sweden hasn't had a prime minister over
the age of 65. if you're looking for an
explanation for why Sweden didn't lock
down during covet and many people still
are looking for an explanation this
seems like it might be a good place to
start led by its relatively young
government Sweden didn't Implement mask
mandates they didn't close the schools
and restaurants and force everyone
regardless of their age to stay in their
little pods children didn't miss years
of education and critical Social
Development small businesses weren't
destroyed pastors weren't hauled out of
church services and thrown in prison and
after all that after ignoring the
infinite wisdom of Tony fauci and the
World Health Organization Sweden
recorded the lowest excess death rate of
any European nation during covet in fact
Sweden's excess death rate was half of
Mayor of of our countries suicide and
overdoses didn't Spike the morgues
weren't overrun with coveted fatalities
people over the age of 70 in many cases
voluntarily stayed home
for everyone else life continued as
normal now in retrospect these are maybe
some of the benefits of having leaders
on the right end of the Actuarial Table
as the last few years have demonstrated
when politicians aren't themselves five
seconds from Keeling over dead they're
less likely to bring down all of society
in a desperate attempt to prolong their
own lives
on the other hand when you're governed
by a gerundocracy especially a secular
gerontocracy which has nothing to look
forward to after death then you can't
count on that kind of stability
stability you can't be assured that your
leaders won't declare an emergency and
take away your rights any more than you
could be assured that they won't start
World War III in Ukraine because they
want to play Churchill with the with the
time they have left on Earth
it's no secret the United States has
transformed into a gerontocracy in the
last several years right now uh roughly
one-fourth of Congress is over the age
of 70. and that number has never been
higher in American history
in 1900 nearly 40 percent of the
politicians in the Senate and the house
were in their 40s that number is now
down to just 20 percent
and of course as we know the current
president is now the oldest sitting
president to ever hold the office Joe
Biden will turn 81 in just a couple of
months in fact presidents now are so old
that the two Far and Away Front Runners
for their party's nominations Biden and
Trump are both older than Bill Clinton
than Bill Clinton is now who was elected
to his first term three decades ago so
when a current president is older than a
former president who's been out of
office for over 20 years
you know something is wrong
but you already knew all this I mean by
this point it's not exactly a secret
that Joe Biden is old
when it's only become apparent in recent
days however is the extent of Joe
Biden's decline as well as the
willingness of his staff to put his
mental Decay on full display for
everyone to see
you know we're all used to seeing
footage of Biden falling apart or
falling down or falling apart and then
falling down in front of the cameras but
we're not used to seeing is what happens
Sunday night in Hanoi Joe Biden was in
Vietnam supposedly to project
strength against China the idea is that
Vietnam the United States will work
together in the new strategic
partnership that will somehow deter the
Chinese government from say invading
Taiwan
but in the end in a shocking turn of
events Joe Biden did not project
strength against China instead Biden led
a rambling 30-minute Press Conference
during which he admitted that he was
just following orders from his staffers
by calling on pre-selected reporters and
then Biden appeared to lose his train of
thought about a dozen times
before saying out loud that he was going
to bed watch the light for and uh let's
see
I'm just following my orders here and
have a game plan he may have a game plan
he just hasn't shared it with me but I
tell you what I don't know about you but
I'm going to go to bed
that is
maybe the one single quote that most
encapsulates Biden's presidency it's the
quote he'll be remembered by I don't
know about you but I'm going to bed
now I have to say I have to admit that
at first I was a little underwhelmed by
Trump's sleepy Joe nickname for Biden
mostly because I would have preferred an
alliteration like um geriatric Joe or
Bumble and Biden something like that but
it turns out that Trump trump really
nailed it he really did and this was not
one isolated senior moment during the
presser either this went on for a while
towards the end of his press
availability Joe Biden referred to the
southern hemisphere as the third world
before realizing that's not something
you're supposed to say out loud and then
Joe Biden's press secretary like the man
behind the curtain Cuts him off
mid-sentence
jazz music starts playing the only thing
they were missing was the big cartoon
hook to drag him off stage uh watch this
we talked about at the conference
overall we talked about stability we
talked about making sure that the third
world the excuse me third world the uh
the the uh the southern hemisphere had
access to change it had access we it
wasn't confrontational at all thank you
everybody this men's account press
conference thanks everyone
thank you
[Music]
raising with every person I met with Mr
President
[Applause]
the president of the United States
everybody I don't think we've ever seen
that before I don't think we've ever
seen staffers cut off a presidential
press conference in mid-sentence because
the president is babbling too much
and as embarrassing embarrassing as this
is it would be a mistake to write it off
as yet another Joe Biden gaffe and then
just move on and that's inevitably how
these kinds of Clips are typically spun
in the media the right uses them to say
ah Biden is old and the left just
ignores them and then that's it but
there's something very significant about
this and perhaps the most significant
takeaway from the whole incident is that
is that this press conference happened
at all at no point did anyone in the
White House apparently or the Pentagon
or the state department veto the idea of
Joe Biden taking a trip to Vietnam where
he would inevitably clown himself on
camera why is that
they knew he'd humiliate himself and the
country does every time he's asked to
speak off the cuff
they knew that
and they also knew that unless they
intervened he'd never shut up at the
podium this is also why he's given so
few press conferences especially when
compared to to recent presidents
especially Donald Trump
so why was he up there at all I mean why
go through the trouble of scheduling
this trip and why is Joe Biden began
rambling did White House staffers twist
the knife in such a it's an overt public
fashion embarrassing him intentionally
like that
Joe Biden's own press secretary played
him out with lounge music against his
wishes while he was still talking
it's hard to think of a more obvious way
to humiliate a president of the United
States so if we're trying to to
intimidate China this is a strange
strategy to say the least
on the other hand if the goal was to
give Xi Jinping a laugh and convince him
that Taiwan is his for the taking then
actually the bite Administration just
succeeded Beyond its wildest imagination
the US government by sending Joe Biden
to Hanoi erased any doubt in Beijing as
to the capability of Joe Biden to stand
up for Taiwan or any other country in
the region
you have to wonder if that was the real
point of the trip
maybe an Administration that's beholden
to China wanted to send a signal to
Beijing that they have nothing to worry
about
if that's the case then Joe Biden's
presser is just one of many such signals
that have been sent to our adversaries
in recent weeks 81 year old Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell isn't
going to push back on China's
territorial Ambitions anytime soon that
much is clear he's no longer able to
reliably answer questions from the media
without freezing up completely in
between reaffirming his indefinite
commitment to spending billions of
taxpayer dollars on Ukraine Mitch
McConnell is doing his best impression
of a stroke victim now you've likely
seen the clips of McConnell standing at
the microphone staring blankly off into
space unable to speak
somehow managing to make John fetterman
look downright communicative by
comparison
now of course McConnell's physician
after that happened
wrote a letter kind of a uh nothing to
see here a letter insisting that
McConnell is in Tip-Top shape
but you would have to have dementia
yourself to believe that you know for
most homeowners window replacement isn't
something they've done before and for
many it's not something they really want
to do but rather something they have to
do well if you've put off replacing
windows in your home because it's too
expensive I have great news for you you
can now get a free in-home window
consultation and free price quote from
Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process and
an exclusive product right now Renewal
by Anderson is offering free in-home or
virtual consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments and zero
interest for a year fix Walsh to 200 300
for your free consultation and to save
375 off every window and 750 off every
door these savings won't last long so be
sure to check it out by texting Walsh to
200 300 that's Walsh to 200 300 texting
privacy policy in terms of conditions
posted at textplan Dot us texting
enrolls for recurring automated text
marketing messages message data rates
apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details you know since Romy Wade was
overturned the left has lost their mind
making abortion their official Sacrament
but despite this the pro-life efforts
are still booming you heard that right
despite the narrative that pro-lifers
that you hear about pro-lifers they have
not gone away they've increased in
number as one of the largest pro-life
organizations in the world no one's in a
better position than 40 Days for life to
end abortion in each state in a
post-rural America four days for life is
uh changing hearts and Minds in the most
blue pro-abortion States they've had a
record number of locations since Roe was
overturned and they grew in both
volunteers and locations with about 1
million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you can help them fight the
ongoing legal Battles by protecting free
speech for their volunteers by giving a
tax deductible gift of any amount at
40daysforlife.com that's
40daysforlife.com
last week to give another example 83
year old Nancy Pelosi claimed that she's
running again to represent San Francisco
because she's in she is in gratitude to
her constituents who really uh need her
to address the challenges the city is
facing watch
I feel very exhilarated by the
encouragement I had to continue
representing my great city of San
Francisco you have the white house
behind you I have homes in San Francisco
behind it and that is my my strength and
the um needs that our our city had right
now really call for me to stay another
term I um had the privilege of
representing San Francisco for a long
time I've had and they had given me the
latitude to serve as Speaker as leader
for over 20 years and whip as well visit
87 countries served 30 years on the
intelligence committee all of those
things but at the same time being
Central Central to my service was
representing my district and gratitude
to them for that I have agreed to stay
on another term in order to help meet
the needs that we have now
how generous of her in gratitude she's
going to remain in power I'm so grateful
that I will not relinquish power until I
am until I'm dead that's the only way
I'm going to relinquish it because I'm
so grateful
you know in San Francisco fecal matter
is all over the place robberies are so
frequent that news reporters can't cover
crime anymore without getting robbed
themselves the city's Office Buildings
are empty therefore what San Francisco
needs now Nancy Pelosi says is more of
the same leadership that put them in
that position to begin to begin with
what it needs most of all is an ancient
decrepit old woman who's been in
politics for 40 years and accomplished
absolutely nothing the entire time
and somehow that sales pitch will work
Nancy Pelosi will indeed win re-election
assuming that she can survive to that
point in fact if we're being honest it
may not even be necessary that she
survives last year a Democrat
Pennsylvania state representative named
Tony DeLuca was re-elected even even
though he died a month before election
day
and in that same election coincidentally
enough John fetterman became one of
Pennsylvania's two senators even though
he hasn't been able to string together
sentences uh for a long time
and you've seen all the painful videos
over the last year or so and in case
you're wondering if fetterman has maybe
improved in recent weeks the answer is
that he has not
here he was just just to show you
filming a campaign video for Bob Casey
while wearing his signature hobo hoodie
during which Casey is basically holding
back laughter because of how absurd the
whole thing is watch
hey Bob Casey John Federman hey
everybody hey last year you all helped
elect John fetterman of the United
States Senate I need your help in 2024.
please chip in whatever you can I'm
telling you how serious it is that we
make sure we keep Bob Casey in the
Senate right now can you help chipping
in a couple bucks to make sure we keep
Bob Casey right here in this Senate
right now Bob Casey thanks John
fetterman
hey last year you guys elected a
cucumber to the Senate so if you don't
really if you don't elect me then then
I'm gonna be very insulted so if you're
gonna like this guy then why wouldn't
you also elect me
it's an interesting pitch I mean he
makes a good point actually
the 54 year old adult male says can you
help chipping in a couple bucks this is
serious
uh Pennsylvania uh you know this is a
guy who wants to represent Pennsylvania
in the U.S Senate can't even bother to
take off the hoodie and put on a suit
John Federman though is not an elderly
man but he's the kind of politician who
could only get elected in a gerontocracy
only a country that has stopped caring
about mental competence would even
contemplate electing someone like
fetterman to represent a state of 13
million people
and and we are long past that point
Dianne Feinstein doesn't understand much
but she understands that at least she
currently represents a state of 40
million people even after surrendering
power of attorney to her daughter
Feinstein is also apparently surrendered
legislative powers to her staff who told
her to shut up and vote I in the middle
of a hearing just last month uh this is
a pretty incredible clip watch this
note the presence of a quorum we will
now vote to report the defense
Appropriations Bill favorably subject to
ameth coloral
Senator Feinstein
um you say aye pardon me
uh to say I I would like to support a
yes vote on this
it provides 823 billion that's an
increase of 26 billion for the
Department of Defense
and it funds priorities submitted
Francisco
yeah just say I okay just
hi thank you Senator Durbin Senator Reed
now when you watch that uh beyond the
obvious point which is that Diane Dianne
Feinstein is a decaying husk who
shouldn't even have a driver's license
much less a senate seat notice again how
the staff handle the situation they just
come right out and tell Feinstein what
to do in full view of the public
they're not ashamed in any way of
admitting that they are running
Feinstein's office
in that respect they're just like Joe
Biden's handlers who have no problem
silencing the president United States
with jazz music like he's a drunk winner
at some award show that nobody watches
what this shows us is not simply that
we're living in a gerontocracy I mean
it's it's it's much worse than that
these episodes reveal that like the late
Soviet Empire we've actually gotten used
to living in a gerontocracy we're not
ashamed of it anymore
political operatives whose entire job is
to Shield their bosses from Bad press
have no problem shoving this in our
faces
this means that our gerontocracy is much
more than an international embarrassment
it's now a full-blown National Security
crisis
they aren't just laughing at our leaders
in East Asia right now
this isn't just social media fodder for
them at this moment our enemies are
proceeding with the understanding that
our government is incapable of holding a
press conference
much less mounting any kind of defensive
response to a surprise attack
and unfortunately for all of us
when it comes to that they're probably
right
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts